today we're listing the best a
transformation quirks that exist in my
ear academia and at the end I'll let you
know which of them I ranked in my top
three for those of you who are unsure
transformations are one of three types
of quirks that exist in Maya academia
they essentially allow the user to alter
their body in some way with an obvious
example being curium is hardening and
that's kind of my subtle way of letting
you guys know that he's not on this list
but before we begin
thank you all for getting the channel to
40,000 subscribers less than two months
ago we didn't even have 1000 subscribers
so I'm incredibly grateful and I hope it
inspires any one of you watching to keep
going at what you love because
eventually you will improve and see the
results that you want but with that out
of the way let's get into the video so
Wyatt place on this list we have the
quirky known as meatball which is
possessed by a second-year student and
she cares who hi now we first saw this
quirk in season 3 during the provisional
license exam and it restarts out for a
lot of gross but very powerful ways and
its most basic meatball allows the user
to manipulate their own flesh and
separate it from their body the user can
then control the flesh with telekinesis
and as we see from these clips he can
walk them into different shapes that fit
specific needs and also use them as
projectiles and while back ago was able
to destroy the balsa flesh pretty easily
this quirk has another ability that
makes it just the worst
once the flesh makes contact with
someone the person is then rolled down
into a ball of meat from which they
can't actually escape at least not by
themselves we saw this power used on
Kirishima and back ago and a bunch of
other innocent victims and what's worse
is that the people inside these balls of
flesh can still feel pain but like I
said they don't have any means of
escaping so it's pretty brutal we got to
be thankful that this power isn't
possessed by a villain I mean could you
imagine what earthworm would have done
to all mine if you could turn him into
one of these things
the quirk is arguably one of the most
versatile transformations as the flesh
can be used for long-range attacks and
for defense or just to immobilize
opponents and as we saw during the show
using the telekinesis you can kind of
like send off one piece of flesh to do
its own thing and then it can catch
enemies by surprise from behind the main
drawback is that people inside these
bowls of flesh will be released if the
user takes enough damage and one final
thing on this the user of this quirk is
called CG and unsurprisingly his name
contains the kanji for flesh he's also
very very annoying now in seventh place
we have the quirk
as black and this is honestly one of my
favorite transformations this quirk
allows the user to merge their body into
anything that is dark-colored regardless
of the size or the mass so vantablack
which is the hero name of the student
who has this quirk he could merge into
something as Tiny as a fly and control
his movements or he could merge into
something massive like the pyramids at
nighttime I don't know why he would ever
do that but I mean he could the only
downside that I can see is that once the
light turns on vantablack is forcibly
ejected from whatever he's hiding in but
still this quark has crazy stealth
potential as you can literally hide in
the shadows and then average people like
people say they hide in the shadows as a
metaphor but no this guy can literally
hide in them and if you want to
infiltrate a secure location say the she
has saikai base for example you could
just merge yourself into someone's shoes
or that genes or whatever we'll be
seeing this quirk animated in season 5
and I honestly cannot wait now moving on
to sixth place we have permeation and
this is a quirk that you should all be
pretty familiar with by now this quote
was possessed by Mario but the only
person who has it right now is probably
me rheostat permeation gives the user
the ability to face through matter and
as we've previously seen murió master
disk work to be able to face both his
entire body or just individual parts in
this clip we see him phasing his hand
through over his palm and then what's
the rest of his arm is still phased his
fist becomes tangible again and whacks
overall in the face this is truly one of
the most unbeatable quotes ever created
because whilst the user isn't tangible
you literally can't do any damage the
only time you can get them is when their
quirk is not activated also we saw that
Mero has a technique in which he
permeates his entire body and then falls
through the ground only to be repelled
upwards at high speeds when he turns off
his quirk this is what he used to defeat
class 1a single-handedly what spun naked
I might add by applying the power in
this way this quote can be used as a
form of teleportation in addition to
making the user essentially invincible
if used correctly the main drawback of
this quirk is that the user's primary
senses don't work because everything
just passes through them what that means
in practice is that when mirror yo
permeates his entire body he's unable to
see anything or hear anything and that's
a pretty big deal but as we've seen with
proper mastery of this power it becomes
one of the best quacks out there and
HUL not being able to see thing it kind
of becomes irrelevant as always said
that even as a student Miriah was closer
to being number one hero than most
professionals so yeah you can imagine
that this quirk is pretty damn good now
moving on to fifth place we have the
quirk known as muscle augmentation which
we saw used by muscular in season three
so this quirk allows the person to
increase the size of their muscles until
they can't even be contained by the
person's skin now this gives the user a
ridiculous amount of power speed and
durability and yes while muscular was
defeated by a fourteen-year-old high
school kid you got to remember guys deku
has one very important thing and that my
friends is called plot armor muscular
was able to withstand the strength of a
100% Detroit's mass which is literally
all might levels of power so if you want
to talk about raw strength then this
transformation right here is elite we
also saw it used by another character in
the manga but that will be explained in
my pro hero arc review that's coming out
within like two or three weeks okay so
at fourth place we have a quirk that has
only ever been seen in the manga so far
so if you want to avoid any spoilers for
what is likely to be the second half of
season 5 then pause this video and skip
to the timestamp on-screen this
character hasn't been seen in any
capacity before so if you've not read
the manga then you won't know who he is
but if you really don't mind at fourth
place we have the quirk known as stress
which is possessed by read estro this
allows the user to store up their stress
over a period of time and then convert
that into raw power now in practice this
gives the user can't efficacious an
unbelievable strength and speed so read
estro used this quirk take identify his
arm and then wipe out a bunch of league
of villain clones in one hit when he
reaches over 80% of his power his body
gets even bigger and gets covered with
this black energy and if you look at all
the damage this caused I mean it's
pretty impressive you can't deny that
the downside to this quirk is that in
order to use it you have to build up a
lot of stress which probably isn't
healthy and if you're not building
stress then you're not really doing
anything to help your quirk then again
many of us are pretty stressed
regardless and can't transform into
gigantic monsters so I guess it's a
useful way of using your stress I guess
and when he reaches a hundred percent he
can discharge black waves of raw energy
from both of his hands so against a
normal opponent whose name isn't sugar
aki this would definitely be
lethal now in third place we have a time
because these quirks are very similar so
to start with if you saw my video
explaining giganto machi as multiple
quirks which i recommend you to check
out as well then you'll know that one of
his abilities is that his body grows
physically larger the more he fights
when we look at this ability in
isolation and disregard his other quirks
it's a pretty useful ability but I feel
like this quirk is so great because guy
got tamaki is the one that has it if you
take him out of the equation and give
the same ability to I don't know
principal Nez sue
he's not gonna last very long because at
the very start of the fight you could
just take him out in one here now the
reason garganta machi is tired is
because once I thought about it I
realized that this power to grow bigger
the more you fight is basically a harder
to activate version of mount ladies
quirk I mean she can transform pretty
big and she doesn't really need to do
all of that the only reason I didn't
feel comfortable putting her above him
is because the owner that Gurgaon Tamaki
would enter quicker than you could say
now just quickly before we move on to
the number two spot I'm releasing this
15% off discount code on all the merch
for this channel to celebrate hitting
40,000 subscribers the code will last
for one week after I post this video so
do be sure to use it while you can okay
so a second place on this list we have
the quirk known as folder body which is
possessed by the new number four pro
hero headshot
this transformation quirk allows him to
control the thinness of his body even
going so far as to make his body as flat
as a sheet of paper where have I seen
this before he can also transform
different sections of his body a will as
we see in this clip here headshot can
used this quirk so precisely but he can
cut off the blood flow to people's
brains so that they almost instantly
lose consciousness which is what he did
to cure Aguirre as you can imagine this
quirk is great for passing through tight
spaces and also for infiltrating places
that other heroes can't get into and on
top of that Ed Shaw is so fast that he
can transform faster than the speed of
sound we saw during the battle at Kamino
that folder body could be used to shoot
the user into the air by transforming
their body into this thin drill type
shape and I don't exactly know how it
works but but let's just go with it
his technique has actually rated a 5 out
of 6 in the ultra analysis book so it's
implied that his usage of this Quogue
can get even better but with that said
the last quirk on this list is
Manifest now this quirk is possessed by
Tamaki emoji key and it allows the user
to transform their limbs into the chosen
characteristics of anything they Eve and
this is shown to include non edible
things like crystals so in theory he can
copy the quotes of other people but in
order to do that he kind of has to take
a bite out of them which Tamaki
personally wouldn't do too often nearly
anything you eat is going to have some
kind of potential benefit whether it's
an entire swordfish or a clam or
tentacles or wings from a chicken I'd be
really interested to see if he can use
those wings that actually fly through
the sky like corks does that would be
pretty cool and I don't know if you guys
have seen the clips yet but I got to
play ones justice to Bandai Namco and
when I was there Tamaki did have an
ability that allowed him to fly properly
with these wings but yeah the main
drawback of this quirk is that in order
to activate it the food has to still be
in the users digestive system which
means that if they captured obviously
you know if you caption you don't have
access to food then you're pretty
screwed
but finally we've listed all the quirks
that were worthy of a space on this list
so now I'm gonna tell you my top three
so at third place I have meatball as I
already said it's a really versatile
quirk especially as far as
transformation quirks go the person
using it can take out a lot of other
people simultaneously and if you hit
someone who's stronger than you such as
I don't know all for one Oregon tamaki
yeah if you hit them with this thing
then people who look unbeatable you can
actually take them out quite easily the
silver medal goes to muscle augmentation
the power this quirk gives you is
incredible and yes while a user with
meatball could in theory very easily
defeat a person with muscle augmentation
remember that this quirk gives the user
SuperSpeed as well so as long as they
see them me they can avoid it pretty
quickly if anything this muscle
augmentation quirk is just an uglier
version of one for all if you think
about it if you think about it it kind
of is and in the number one spot the
gold medal the best transformation quirk
that exists in my academia now you guys
probably could have guessed this already
just from how just how much I was hyping
it up but my personal favorite and the
one that I think is undoubtedly the best
is permeation what is there to say about
this quirk that hasn't already been said
the user is genuinely untouchable a
quirk that means you can't be touched is
a quirk that also means you can't be
beat except by maybe professor Aizawa
but even if you use the argument I mean
the only way I saw it could be him is by
turning off his quark so the fact is as
long as this crack is on as long as it's
activated you can't beat the person
every other choir that exists is useless
against a guy who can become intangible
at will
so I gotta give the number one spot to
permeation here but there you have it
guys that was my list of the top eight
transformation quirks if you liked this
video then be sure to subscribe and
share this around as I'm aiming to hit
50,000 subscribers by the end of March
see you next week peace out
you